with this one  rachel  hi hey  hi  uh everything okay bud  not really what are you doing this is  gonna sound really crazy but i'm gonna  need to see that ring for just one  second one second have you lost your  mind i'm gonna give it right back i  promise you guys please randall it's  really important can i no bro go sit  down randall give me the ring please  just okay randall don't look at him look  at me randa randall right one second put  the ring on my finger no random listen  to me randall look at me ring on my face  give me the ring give me just one second  put a ring on  it please love okay  with this ring yes i'm so sorry about  this  [Music]  snowmobile oh boy  anybody hurt  sonic ah hawaii